[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau data d
interdire quoi de mieux qu'un jour de
pâques pour nous intéresser au pape
françois qui vient de fêter le huitième
anniversaire de son pontificat le pape
est il de gauche comme le soupçonne ces
adversaires est il vraiment en train de
réformer l'église catholique de la
rendre plus démocratique en défendant
les pauvres les migrants les divorcés
les homosexuels de la protestante ise en
donnant du pouvoir ou laïcs aux femmes
en particulier et d'abandonner son
centre l'europe pour lui préférer la
périphérie l'amérique du sud l'afrique
et même l'asie qui semble l'intéresser
bien plus que la france ou l'italie
alors pour répondre à toutes ces
questions je reçois aujourd'hui très
eric monier bonjour frédéric que vous
avez été pendant quatre ans
correspondant du quotidien la croix à
rome et chef de son service religion
vous venez de faire paraître aux presses
du châtelet le peuple qui voulait
changer l'église alors première question
parce que beaucoup cela pose le pape
françois est il de gauche à votre avis
bah écoutez un peuple qui déclare que
les médecins qui pratiquent des ivg sont
des avorteurs et sont des assassins
pardon est il un peuple de gauche
donc pour vous il n'est pas de gauche il
est payé est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est un pape de drop ou est ce que ça
veut dire tout simplement que c'est un
pape
voilà c'est un pape c'est à dire que ses
adversaires qui sont souvent de droite
pensent qu'il est de gauche mais c'est
avant tout un pape qui assure la lignée
d'une certaine de façon de se situer
dans le monde
pourtant vous faites partie de ceux qui
le qualifient de réformateurs c'est donc
à chaque peuple
c'est un pape quand même qu'il veut
changer l'église c'est le titre de votre
livre est ce que pour autant il ya t-il
tout changer c'est ce qu'on va voir
ensemble mais c'est un réformateur
absolument il a il a été élu pour ça il
a été élu pour réformer l'église pour la
changer de fond en comble et c'est son
objectif clairement affiché
et à son âge il a plu
grand chose à perdre il a 84 ans et donc
il est bien décidé à aller jusqu'au bout
et pour tout cela à prendre le temps
qu'il faut c'est un homme qui sait
prendre son temps puisque vous l'avez
souligné son pontificat a d'ores et déjà
dépassé en longueur celui de son
prédécesseur le pape benoît 16
alors justement vous parlez de 2,16 il
se trouve qu'on est dans une situation
inédite il y a deux papes et tous les
deux d'ailleurs vive tôt ou au vatican
alors qu'est ce que ça change est ce que
le est ce que le pape françois a
véritablement les mains libres
oui je pense que fondamentalement lille
main il a les mains libres mais je pense
aussi que benoît 16 a commis une erreur
en souhaitant rester au vatican
le fait de porter le titre de pape
émérite le fait d'être habillé comme un
pape et le fait d'habiter à quelques
dizaines de mètres de du de son
successeur
du point de vue stratégique du point de
vue politique c'est pas une bonne chose
parce que là plusieurs reprises on peut
on peut estimer que le pape le pape
ratzinger comme on dit à rome benoît 16
le paquet émérite a été manipulé par un
certain nombre d'adversaires de dupas
françois qui souhaitait lui faire
prendre un certain nombre de positions
opposées au pape françois alors ensuite
il s'est récusé
mais voilà je pense que cette double
présence pontificale n'est pas une bonne
chose
et justement alors on sait qu'il y a il
a des adversaires
le pape françois tous les papes ans en
ont eu mais ce que est ce que le pape
émérite le pape ratzinger est un
adversaire ou est ce que on le refait
parler on lui prête des dépenses et
qu'il n'a pas forcément
donc je pense que fondamentalement
benoît 16 n'est pas un adversaire du pas
françois benoit 16 c'est bien que le pas
françois n'aborde pas les questions de
la même façon que lui mais
fondamentalement bonhoure et 16 laisse
faire vivre et gouverner le pas françois
est tout à fait comme il le comme il le
souhaite
il ya ce film que on a pu voir sur
netflix qui s'intitule les deux papes
avec anthony hopkins dans le rôle du
pape ratzinger
ce film
assez passionnant y compris pour ceux
qui ne croient pas en dieu qui ne
s'intéressent pas forcément où pape
laissent entendre que ce serait
ratzinger qui auraient choisi françois
comme successeur françois serait déjà
leurs proches de la retraite et
ratzinger l'aurait sorti de là pour le
convaincre de se présenter
pensant comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure que il était nécessaire que
c'était le moment de changer un certain
nombre de choses et qu'il était la
personne idoine
est ce que cette vision un peu un peu
conte de fées vous vous ai juste d'une
manière ou d'une autre
alors ce film est excellent sur la forme
sur le fond ce qui est ce qui est avancé
ne correspond pas à la réalité
sur la forme les réalisateurs ont fait
un excellent travail de mise en scène de
la vie au vatican de la relation entre
les hommes de pouvoir au vatican et
c'est de ce point de vue là c'est très
bien vu mais sur le fond ratzinger
n'avait quasiment pas de relation avec
berg olio ils se connaissent très peu et
en tout cas ils ne se sont pas
rencontrés avant et on sait bien comment
s'est passée l'élection du pape françois
est donc en nous quelqu'un on peut dire
que ratzinger à manipuler après
construit l'élection du père françois
alors justement comment s'est passée
cette élection frédéric mounier parce
que pour tous ceux qui soit parce qu'ils
ne croient pas en dieu soit peking parce
qu'ils ne sont pas catholiques ou tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont pas autant
au courant de vous des us et coutumes du
vatican une élection
d'un pape ça se passe comment vous avez
l'air de dire qu'il ya des forces en
présence on a presque l'impression que
vous avez lu les sondages avant et que
de même que nous ont dit voilà ce que
veulent les français les français nous
lance un message il y aurait ça aussi au
moment du conclave
oui naturellement alors ce conclave a
été marquée d'abord par un gigantesque
et fête surprise qui a été la démission
de benoit 16 je peux vous assuré parce
que j'étais présent à rendre cette
époque là et j'ai rencontré très
rapidement après la après sa
renonciation des cardinaux qui étaient
présents dans la salle même où le pape a
annoncé sa renonciation
tout le monde était absolument sidéré
tétanisés ça a été une véritable
surprise
et pourtant dieu sait si le vatican et
le palais des rumeurs le palais des
cancans et le palais des des petits
potins partagez donc là le secret avait
été gardée jusqu'au tout dernier moment
donc cette élection était marqué par cet
effet de sidération et donc par cet
effet d'inquiétude
beaucoup des cardinaux qui se sont
rassemblés pour le conclave ne se
connaissaient pas il faut pas croire que
les cardinaux se connaissent tous par
coeur et vivront y vivent aux quatre
coins du monde
je me souviens très bien d'un cardinal
africain qui avaient voté lors du
précédent conclave en 2005 et qui
m'avait expliqué simplement que lors de
ce conclave le soir de retour dans sa
cellule et bien il regardait sur
internet pour savoir qui étaient ses
voisins et pour savoir qui étaient les
autres les autres cardinaux alors plus
sérieusement la question qui se posait
c'était de tirer les conséquences de
cette renonciation est donc de savoir
exactement pour quelles raisons le pape
benoît avait démissionné et à quoi il
fallait remédier
clairement si le pape si le pape benoît
16 a démissionné c'est parce qu'il n'en
pouvait plus physiquement ça c'est sûr
et aussi psychologiquement c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient environnés de scandale
ils étaient environnés
son majordome sont le personnel de son
bureau avait volé des documents sur son
bureau qu'on a retrouvé le lendemain
dans la presse italienne
il y avait des scandales financiers et
il n'en pouvait plus il faut savoir que
benoît 16 n'était pas un gouvernant
c'était avant tout un théologien un
intellectuel de très haute volée c'était
pas du tout un gouvernant il avait
pourtant été élu en 2005 pour remédier
déjà à ce qu'on connaissait comme était
un comme étant les mots congénitaux du
vatican et on pourra reparler tout à
l'heure si vous le voulez bien mais en
fait il n'avait pas les moyens
psychologiques personnelles il n'avait
pas une équipe derrière lui ce n'était
pas un homme habitué à trancher c'était
pas un homme habitué à à prendre des
décisions politiques et donc les
cardinaux se concertant vous savez avant
le conclave ya ce qu'on appelle les
congrégations générales
c'est à dire que tous ces hommes se
retrouvent et les prises de paroles ce
succès est un peu une sorte de de remue
ménage pendant plusieurs jours et donc
ils se succèdent et ils prennent la
parole pour dire voilà le profil du pape
que je souhaiterais voilà les dossiers
qu'il faut travailler etc
et donc c'est au fil de ces grandes
d'irrigation général que d'une part une
sorte de consensus s'est déclaré à
l'extérieur du conclave notamment pour
nous autres journalistes
nous étions tous absolument convaincu
que ça serait mon seigneur le cardinal
angelo scola archevêque de turin qui
serait élu pape
et pourtant à l'intérieur des
congrégations générales c'est un autre
courant qui s'est dessinée c'est
notamment un courant de ras-le-bol des
magouilles à l'italienne il faut dire
les choses comme elles sont et je peux
expliquer pourquoi c'est aussi un
courant de de retour à l'essentiel de la
fois de retour à l'essentiel de
l'évangile et donc il est arrivé un
moment où le cardinal bergoglio
archevêque de buenos ars en argentine et
bien a pris la parole s'est exprimé
pendant 3 minutes et il a exprimé
quelques vérités très très simple ce
message a été a été publié ensuite je l'
ai repris dans mon livre et là il ya eu
un déclic et on peut considérer
aujourd'hui a posteriori que l'élection
s'est jouée à ce moment là les
magouilles alitalia lit on vous parlait
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être
alors écoutez il faut se souvenir que
l'italie est un pays très neuf est un
pays où l'état n'existe pas ou est très
très peu existants l'unité il ya deux
unités de base en italie via l'unité
sociale qui est le village qui est la
famille pardon et l'unité territoriale
qui est le village et c'est comme ça que
dans les très grandes difficultés
économiques ou ce débat ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que la
population survit et donc la dérive de
ceux de ce système clanique familiale et
villageois et bien sûr le pousse à son
extrême ce système de solidarité devient
la mafia et 2 fait une forme de système
mafieux avait investi une partie du
vatican notamment à travers la banque
que à travers la banque du vatican
vous soulevez un très très bien la
cardinale de curry qui m'avait expliqué
qu'ils n'étaient pas italien et qui
m'avait qui m'avait expliqué qu'il était
courant de voir des messieurs bien ni
avec plutôt l'apparence d'hommes
d'affaires qui venait voir d'autres
cardinaux de curry et qui leur
expliquait tout le bien qu'il pensait de
l'église des actions de solidarité de
l'église et qui à la fin de l'entretien
transmettait des mallettes pleines de
billets en liquide comme ces courants en
italie en italie on transporte beaucoup
liquide on paye beaucoup en liquide et
très souvent la machine de la carte
bleue est en panne et donc à ce moment
là l'argent pouvait ainsi rentrer dans
la banque du vatican et la banque du
vatican à l'insu de son plein gré de son
plein gré servette organismes de
blanchiment et donc tout ça tout le
monde le savait tout le monde le savait
et les cardinaux du monde entier
souhaité remédier à cet aspect un peu
noir de la gestion de l'organe central
de l'église de la curie et du vatican
et donc c'est en partie pour cette
raison là que le pape a été élu alors
justement un des points qu'on que
certains reprochent à opale françois
c'est que l'europe
le centre de la chrétienneté juste
jusque là
eh bien le peuple lui préférerait la
périphérie au fond il
il serait un peu fâché avec l'europe
oui c'est tout à fait juste
et ça a été affichée dès le début ça a
été affichée dès le début dès les
premiers temps on a vu que ce pape qui
lui même vient des périphéries qui lui
même est un enfant de migrants ce pape
dès le début a voulu s'attacher aux
fractures aux fractures delà de la
planète
au lieu de souffrance au lieu de
difficulté et on l'a vu assez vite
lorsque les nominations de cardinaux
sont intervenus ce papa élus 79 cardy a
choisi par nos 79 cardinaux électeurs
depuis son élection sur un total de 126
dont vous voyez que le cardinal le
conclave qui décidera de son successeur
est déjà en quelque sorte préprogrammés
et très vite dès les premiers
consistoire c'est à dire dès les
premières nominations de cardinaux eh
bien on a vu que l'attention était
portée sur et bien sûr la papouasie
nouvelle guinée sur l'indonésie sur
haïti sur la république centrafricaine
et que le pape oublier ce qu'on appelle
les grands sièges cardinalice vous avez
remarqué que l'archevêque de paris n'est
toujours pas cardinal pour quelles
raisons
et bien parce que ses périphéries pour
elles sont là où l'évangile se joue sont
là où la solidarité la paix et la
justice sont indispensables le pape l'a
dit lorsqu'il est venu à strasbourg
lorsqu'il a fait un discours au conseil
de l'europe
il a expliqué qu'à ses yeux l'europe
était une grand-mère fatigué et que
cette grand-mère fatigué et épuisé et il
se il porte ce diagnostic là aussi sur
les communautés chrétiennes en europe
alors c'est pas toujours bien pris par
les chrétiens européens qui attendent
toujours qu'ils viennent en france par
exemple ou qui attendent toujours qu'ils
viennent au fil de ses déplacements sur
deux
vers l'un ou l'autre pays d'europe mais
il a décidé de venir à bangui en
république centrafricaine il a décidé de
venir en irak on en parlera tout à
l'heure là où ça fait mal là où la
planète à mal là où les hommes et les
femmes au mal et c'est ça qui la choisit
donc le mot périphérie est un mot très
important pour comprendre la vision du
monde et de l'église de ce peuple
mais ils redoutent également le terme de
racines chrétiennes de l'europe il en
redoutent dit-il la tonalité trouve
triomphaliste et vengeresse il préfère
parler de racine au pluriel
il a donné cette interview à la croix
qui était votre journal recyclé c'est
sérieux c'est la loi oui ça va loin
parce que ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
les racines chrétiennes
mais il ne fait pas des racines
chrétiennes un oriflamme il ne fait pas
d'erreur des racines chrétiennes
un slogan de croisade il fait des
racines chrétiennes simplement une
fondation un soubassement qui dont nous
sommes tous héritiers dont nous avons
tous plus ou moins conscience que nous
ne pouvons pas oublier mais ça n'est pas
une raison pour se prévaloir de ce
racines chrétiennes et partir en guerre
contre les autres contre les autres
religions contre les non chrétiens etc
donc voilà son point de vue est tout à
fait clair là dessus mais vraiment
j'insiste sur le le point de vue des
périphéries le pape insiste énormément
sur les périphéries territoriale et
aussi sur les périphéries sociale ce
pack s'intéresse systématiquement aux
plus pauvres aux oubliés à ceux qui sont
les victimes de ce qu'il appelle
l'économie du déchet c'est un peuple qui
est extrêmement sévère contre certaines
conséquences du système capitaliste on y
viendra mais pour en finir avec son
rapport à l'europe que certains trouvent
un peu ambigu quelqu'un comme eric
zemmour il voit le signe que le le pape
abandonne l'europe à l'islam par exemple
alors vous soulignez la une fracture
importante c'est à dire que bon nombre
des opposants au pas françois sont
opposants sur cette base là c'est à dire
qu'ils mettent en évidence une certaine
innocence supposée du pape françois par
rapport à l'islam et donc ils lui
reprochent notamment pour le voyage en
irak qui lui ont reproché de de ceux de
prendre contact et d'entretenir des
relations avec des responsables chiites
et puis ils l'ont il lui avait aussi
reproché quelque temps auparavant
d'entretenir des relations avec l'islam
sunnite
c'est ses opposants de françois pense
que on ne peut pas dialoguer avec les
islam alors que pour le pape françois
c'est très très clairs et c'était vrai
aussi de benoît 16 j'ai un souvenir
extrêmement précis du cardinal français
jean louis tauran qui était le en
quelque sorte qu'une ministre du pape
benoît 16 pour les relations avec les
islam et il m'avait dit très très
clairement pour nous le dialogue est un
impératif le dialogue avec les islam est
un impératif
tout ce que nous pouvons faire ensemble
avec les musulmans notamment en matière
de solidarité d'entr'aide de promotion
sociale d'éducation nous le ferons car
si on ne parle pas si on ne se parle pas
on se tue et malheureusement l'actualité
a montré que s'il n'ya pas le vaccin du
dialogue
et bien il y a le virus de la violence
c'est très clair qui avait été reproché
au pape françois également c'est lors de
son retour de lesbos il avait ramené
dans son avion trois familles syriennes
musulmane plutôt que trois familles
syriennes chrétienne
j'aimais linke pour vous c'est il l'a
pas fait au hasard ça non alors on peut
pas faire la part de ski et
l'improvisation puisque de fait ce geste
était assez inattendu quand même
aideront que voilà on peut pas on peut
pas plaider la préméditation
ce qui est clair c'est que ensuite il
s'est justifié et il reconnaît tout à
fait que ce sont les musulmans qui sont
les premières victimes de certains
délires islamique et donc on ne choisit
pas la religion de ce qu'on vient aider
c'est tout à fait clair et donc c'est
pour ça que ce voyage en irak était un
petit peu compliqué à organiser aussi
c'est parce que tout le monde tout le
monde en irak parmi les parmi les
chrétiens n'est pas persuadé qu'on peut
dialoguer avec ceux d'en face parce que
les fractures sont forts que les
cicatrices sont encore extrêmement vive
et qu'il y a aussi énormément de
réfugiés chrétiens auxquelles il faut
apporter une aide en irak mais le pape
est très clair là dessus on ne choisit
pas la religion de ce qu'on vient aider
et on doit à tout prix même au prix du
sang dialoguer avec ceux qui ne
partagent pas la même foi que nous
l'avenir de l'humanité en dépend pour
ses deux prédécesseurs aussi bien benoît
16 que jean paul 2 l'europe était le
centre de la chrétienne t aujourd'hui on
reproche au pape françois de préférer
les migrants avoir choisi les migrants
il reste que c'est uniquement parce que
lui-même est un fils de migrants ses
parents étaient italiens ils sont
d'émigrer en argentine où est ce qu'il y
a là encore le choix du plus faible
oui c'est le choix du plus faible
c'est le choix de la périphérie c'est le
choix du plus faible c'est le choix de
la périphérie
évidemment ratzinger était lui-même
originaire de la bavière donc c'est
vraiment l'allemagne l'a plus chrétienne
est la plus catholique qui soit et jean
paul ii était lui-même comme ans et
originaire de pologne et c'est l'europe
la plus catholique qui soit donc voilà
il faut pas s'étonner du fait que
un pape venu de la périphérie
s'intéresse avant tout à la paix à ces
périph à ses périphéries là mais c'est
un choix de type évangélique
il s'intéresse aux périphéries de même
que le christ s'intéressait aux
périphéries de son temps il
s'intéressait aux pestiférés aux lépreux
aux aveugles le nez aux adultes air etc
etc
c'est ça le fond de la position du pape
françois et de la même manière alors moi
qui ne suis pas chrétien et qui regarde
ça avec un avec margaret extérieurs tout
simplement et je me dis mais c'est au
fond c'est le message du christ depuis
le début il faut préfère les pauvres le
christ préfère les pauvres dont qui
paraît logique qu'il préfère le
tiers-monde à l'europe mais ça paraît
toujours surprenant vis-à-vis du vatican
il ya toujours des chrétiens et même des
catholiques pour le critiquer ça m'a
toujours paru un mystère donc c'est pas
investir parce que il faut voir que
depuis deux mille ans depuis que le la
petite secte le petit groupe de
chrétiens a commencé à ceux à se
disséminer au sein du moyen-orient puis
de la turquie et publient de la rock etc
il ya toujours eu des dissensions entre
pierre et paul
on se tirait la bourre c'était très
compliqué et sur des questions de fond
et donc depuis deux mille ans les
chrétiens n'ont cessé de se disputer
on se souvient quand même de nos guerres
de de nourrir de religion mais les
chrétiens n'ont cessé de se discuter de
s'opposer de ce centrifuge est en
quelque sorte de faire preuve de 6,6
parité sert tout comme les écolos les
chrétiens ils partagent une même foi
mais ils sont ils sont pas toujours
d'accord entre il se trouve que
historiquement en raison de son alliance
avec un certain nombre de pouvoirs
temporels au fil de l'histoire est bien
le catholicisme est devenue la
confession chrétienne majoritaire avec
aujourd'hui avec aujourd'hui près d'un
milliard trois cents millions de
catholiques
il n'est pas dit que cette situation va
durer et c'est aussi l'un des reproches
qui est fait aux pattes françois par
nombre de ses autres sens c'est de m
péril par ses initiatives et par ses
prises de position de mettre en péril
l'hégémonie du catholicisme à travers le
monde et peut-être de faire en sorte
qu'un jour est bien de le mettre au même
niveau que les dizaines d'églises
orthodoxes qui a dans le monde où des
centaines d'églises protestantes qu'il y
a dans le monde on a l'impression qu'au
cours du 20e siècle notamment mais sans
doute avant et et au moment de la
révolution française c'était la même
chose qu'on a reproché l'église
catholique au fond c'était d'être du
côté de la force d'être du côté du
pouvoir
est-ce que françois dans son sens cela
serait en rupture avec le passé de
l'église où c'est déjà depuis longtemps
que les papes sont passés du côté des
faibles alors c'est vous pose évidemment
là toute la question de l'histoire de
l'église
il est évident que pendant des siècles
et des siècles
le papa était un souverain temporel moi
je me souviens très très bien à rome
encore aujourd'hui toutes les familles
romaines se souviennent que jusqu'en
1870 le souverain pontife était un
souverain temporel et toutes les
familles romaines rond eu des membres de
leur famille qui ont été au service du
vatican
alors ça c'est le petit bout de la
lorgnette il est évident que
historiquement il y a eu des tensions
très fortes et que donc il faut se
souvenir du jansénisme il faut se
souvenir des guerres de religion il faut
se souvenir du gallicanisme de l'ultra
montagny etc
pendant très longtemps pendant des
siècles et des siècles le pouvoir
central de l'église catholique a éprouvé
toutes les difficultés à se dégager de
la gang du pouvoir temporel
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le moment
historique est venu
le vatican ces 44 hectares le vatican
s'est aucune division
aujourd'hui en europe occidentale la
vieille grand mère catholique quand même
singulièrement fatigué époustouflé au
sens au sens propre notamment après la
pandémie on sait qu'aujourd'hui un tiers
des pratiquants ne sont pas revenus dans
les églises on sait que les ressources
financières chutent
on sait que la corrosion en disant de la
sécularisation touche profondément
l'europe que les sorties d'église sont
très importantes et donc le moment est
venu aujourd'hui et c'est ça que le pape
françois a senti le moment est venu
aujourd'hui pour les catholiques de
renouer avec le choeur de l'évangile de
renouer avec le message du christ et
c'est bien ça que à travers l'ensemble
de ces textes et à travers l'ensemble de
ses gestes
c'est ça que le pape françois essaye de
mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui premiers
ont fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
on reprend cette émission sur le pack
françois avec frédéric mounier l'auteur
du pape qui voulait changer l'église
nous sommes le jour de pâques le jour de
pâques
pardonnez moi ce lapsus là la question
que vous posez également dans votre
livre frédéric mounier c est ce que ce
pape ne voudrais pas protestantes ise
l'église en donnant du pouvoir aux laïcs
et aux femmes
une femme cardinal un jour c'est
possible c'est tout à fait possible
c'est tout à fait possible
évidemment ce mot de protestantisation
que vous utilisez c'est un mot qui est
utilisé par les adversaires du pape
donc moi personnellement je suis plutôt
favorable et je me semble plutôt proche
de ce pape l'a donc je ne l'accusé pas
de tentatives de protestantisation mais
il est clair que les adversaires mettre
le doigt sur un point sensible alors ce
qui est attendu prochainement peut-être
dans les jours qui viennent dans les
semaines ou dans les mois qui viennent
c'est un texte fondamental que le pape
va publier qui va s'intituler predica t
evangelion c'est du latin et ça veut
dire prêcher l'évangile et ce pape
ce texte va être donc une constitution
apostolique donc on dit bien ce que
c'est c'est une constitution qui va
modifier profondément le fonctionnement
de l'église de quelle façon et bien en
faisant intervenir deux notions qui sont
très importantes aux yeux du pape
françois c'est d'une part la
collégialité et d'autre part la
synodalité alors si on veut transposer
ça en termes de 2,2 politique
contemporaine
on peut dire que le paven c'est un sort
et instaurer une sorte de démocratie
participative dans l'église c'est à dire
qu'il veut que l'église soit moins
pyramidal que le pouvoir des clercs
c'est à dire des prêtres ordonnés soit
moins important est que l'église soit
plus attentive aux orientations et au
désir exprimé par les communautés par
les communautés paroissiales par les
laïcs hommes et femmes et que donc cette
église prennent une autre une autre
figure alors vous avez évoqué la
question des femmes c'est évidemment les
questions très importantes
il faut se rappeler quand même que sur
le 1,3 milliard de baptisés de baptisés
catholiques dans le monde
la moitié sont des femmes forcément et
que donc il y a environ aujourd'hui 410
bill prêtres dans le monde mais il ya
600 milles religieuse et j'ai relevé un
éditorial dans le supplément féminin de
l'osservatore romano qui existe qui
avaient été mis en oeuvre par le pape
benoît 16 et dans ce sud
en féminin eh bien il ya une très grande
historienne italienne qui a expliqué des
hommes
accepterait-il jamais de se voir
présenter à un concile qui serait
composé uniquement de femmes qui
prendrait des décisions les concernant
et eux aussi
eh bien c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les
décisions concernant l'ensemble de
l'église sont prises par des
institutions le concile et le synode qui
sont en quelque sorte les assemblées
législatives de l'église qui sont
exclusivement masculine
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à présent dans
l'église le pouvoir est liée à
l'ordination l'ordination sacerdotale
si vous êtes ordonné prêtre vous êtes
considéré comme ayant du pouvoir si vous
n'êtes pas vous n'avez pas de pouvoir
c'est précisément ce point là que le
pape voudrait changer alors deux fêtes
il a procédé à un grand nombre de
nominations féminines dont la dernière a
fait un certain bruit puisqu'il s'agit
d'une femme religieuse française soeur
nathalie becquart qui a été nommé numéro
deux du synode des évêques
c'est un petit peu comme si elle avait
été nommée vice présidente de
l'assemblée nationale de l'église avec
droit de vote alors que jusqu'à présent
au synode des évêques
ça peut vous paraître anachronique mais
aussi notre des évêques il y avait que
des évêques qui pouvait voter et c'était
tous des hommes
donc le pape met le pied dans la porte
essaye de faire bouger les choses
il a nommé de très nombreuses femmes
dans des instances internes du vatican
est donc tout son fonctionnement
consiste à ouvrir des portes met le pied
dans la porte
laissez passer les courants d'air et
voir ce qui se passe c'est un
fonctionnement extrêmement jésuites
nous ne sait ce qui va se passer mais au
moins ça circule et ça bouge et au même
moment c'est l'incurie je crois qu'ils
qui refusent les femmes diacres et
l'ordination des hommes des hommes
mariés donc on voit bien qu'il ait pas
tout seul non plus ce pape il ne fait
pas ce qu'il veut
non il ne fait pas ce qu'il veut même si
on dit qu'il est un autocrate et bien je
vais pas ce qu'il veut il ne fait pas ce
qu'il veut parce qu il
les forces d'opposition sont importantes
il ya d'une part une forme d'inertie un
grand nombre de gens au sein de l'église
10 mais pourquoi on ne fait pas comme on
a toujours fait sauf que c'est une
erreur historique parce qu'on n'a pas
toujours fait comme on fait aujourd'hui
donc le papa bien conscient de ça parce
que c'est aussi un intellectuel il sait
bien que cet argument ne tient pas mais
au moins il ya cette inertie et puis à
un certain nombre d'avantagés acquis un
certain nombre de positions établies qui
font que beaucoup d'hommes notamment
freine des quatre fers
et puis il ya aussi l'inquiétude
vis-à-vis de l'avenir c'est à dire que
certains se disent mais où nous
mène-t-il jusqu'où allons nous aller et
qu'est ce qui va se passer
et de fait cette grande réforme qui
était mise en oeuvre par le peuple
cette réforme de la collégialité et de
la synodalité consiste à donner plus de
pouvoir aux communautés locales
alors je vais faire bref mais imaginez
que l'archevêque de bangui 10
moi je suis opposé à l'ordination des
hommes mariés et imaginer que
l'archevêque de buenos aires s ou de
tokyo 10 n'ont finalement compte tenu
des conditions locales social et
culturel dans mon pays bas c'est
important que je puisse ordonner des
hommes mariés et donc là on a
effectivement un risque de schisme un
risque de scission qui est très
important et parmi les fonctions les
attributs du pape ya quand même d'être
le garant de l'unité de l'église
et c'est ça qui en ce moment est en
train de craquer est en train de se
tendre et qui est en train de susciter
un certain nombre de d'inquiétude parmi
le peuple
cela dit on peut comprendre la tentation
de faire comme on a toujours fait
vatican 2 qui avait été voulue par le
pape jean xxiii
on sait à quoi ça aboutit en tout cas on
pense le savoir ça a vidé les églises
alors est ce que c'est parce que ça
s'est passé au même moment mais toujours
est il que l'idée tout à coup d'avoir
affaire à un bon dieu un dieu qui vous
comprend un dieu qui vous pardonne un
dieu qui ne vous en veux pas si vous
n'allez pas l'espèce un dieu qui ne vous
en
veut pas si vous ne vous confesser pas
un dieu à qui que l'on peut suivre sans
pour autant s'habiller comme un prêtre
mais en restant avec un jean et des
baskets
ça a quand même contribué à vider les
églises en tout cas en europe
alors cet argument frédéric taddeï et tu
lis est utilisé par les intégristes
c'est effectivement le grand argument de
monseigneur lefebvre de l'institut saint
pie 10 et de tous les traditionalistes
qui considèrent que le monde a commencé
le monde catholique a commencé à
s'effondrer au moment en 2 vatican ii en
fait les travaux des historiens montre
que non que les églises ont commencé à
se vider bien avant et qu'il s'agit d'un
mouvement de sécularisation qui date en
gros du début du 19e siècle et en gros
de la rue des lumières qui ont précédé
la révolution française et puis ce vaste
mouvement d'autonomisation de la pensée
humaine qui aujourd'hui abouti à une
sécularisation très très forte et qui
fait que aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'européens notamment ne voit plus de
raison d'être simplement à la foi
catholique
et puis vous pouvez rajouter à ça une
rupture essentielle fondamentale est
très importante dans la transmission qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui la culture
catholique fait partie du passé
je discutais récemment encore avec avec
des évêques français qui consigne qui
était absolument étonné de voir que même
le reprendre neveu ou petit neveu ne
connaissez même plus les mots de base de
la foi catholique aujourd'hui donc ce
mouvement est ancien ce mouvement est
fondé sur toute une toute une évolution
alors maintenant effectivement le
concile vatican 2 certains vous disent
que ce concile n'a pas été mis en oeuvre
jusqu'au bout et que notamment
il prévoyait de donner du pouvoir aux
conférences épiscopales il prévoyait de
donner du pouvoir aux assemblées
paroissiales locale et que
on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout qu'on
n'a pas donné de pouvoir aux laïcs et
que notamment durant les dernières
années de jean paul 2 et durant le
pontificat de benoît 16 et bien on a
procédé à la scea la sélection et la
formation de prêtres qui ont des profils
qui sont des profils anciens et qui est
pour lesquels il n'est pas question de
partager le pouvoir
mais là dessus françois est inflexible
notamment parce que françois a été
profondément ébranlée par la crise des
abus sexuels
c'est vrai que on a tendance à peut-être
ne pas comprendre ne pas réaliser à quel
point c'est un traumatisme à l'intérieur
de l'église et notamment à l'intérieur
du vatican
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous donc
comme vous pouvez nous l'expliqué ça
ferait avec mounier alors écoutez il y a
plusieurs lieux plusieurs étapes
il faut dire que l'un de ceux qui a pris
très rapidement la juste mesure du
scandale des abus sexuels et de son
caractère systémique et bien c'était
benoît 16 alors qu'ils n'étaient que le
cardinal ratzinger qui dirigeait la
congrégation pour la doctrine de la foi
il a eu les moyens à ce moment-là de
mener des enquêtes notamment au près en
ce qui concerne les dossiers des
légionnaires du christ et du fondateur
des légionnaires du christ qui était
très proche de jean paul 2 est donc
assez rapidement il a eu tous les
éléments en main pour être absolument
convaincu que le fondateur des
légionnaires du christ grand fort aux
grands pourvoyeurs de vocation à travers
le monde et bien était un criminel
prédateurs pédéraste pédophiles vraiment
un homme absolument détestable
c'était un assassin et le problème key
ratzinger c'est que cet assassin
simultanément arroser la curie de fonds
financiers et de billets et que donc là
il ya eu un scandale extrêmement
important benoît 16 ans n'avait
confiance en avez conscience
jean paul ii n'a pas eu conscience c'est
pour ça que certains remettent en cause
même sa canonisation
ensuite benoît 16 a été élu aussi pour
remédier à cela je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure il n'a pas eu les moyens de le
faire il n'a pas eu la possibilité de le
faire et donc françois est arrivé il a
pris ce dossier
au début il a été un peu dubitatif sur
le mode
certes nous avons des brebis égarées
mais non etc
et puis il ya eu le voyage au chili et
le voyage au chili a été pour lui un
détonateur
c'est à dire que juste avant le voyage
un certain nombre de lanceurs d'alert
ont fait parvenir un message au vatican
en disant attention l'église du chili
est gangrené par les abus sexuels
notamment tel ou tel évêque et il faut
absolument faire quelque chose
le pape a dit non il faut voir tout ça
c'est des ragots etc
et puis très rapidement il a pris
conscience du fait que l'emprise d'un
certain nombre de clercs pédophiles
étaient était vraiment très importante
qu'il y avait eu une sorte de phénomène
de secte au sein de l'église du chili
très rapidement à son retour de voyage
il a pris des mesures
l'ensemble de l'épiscopat chilien a
démissionné et donc à ce moment là le
pape a fait le lien notamment dans sa
fameuse lettre aux catholiques il a fait
le lien très claire entre l'emprise
l'abus de pouvoir et l'abus sexuel et le
cléricalisme
c'est à dire que il a pris conscience du
fait que ce sont des prêtres ordonnés
qui ont utilisé leur pouvoir pour abuser
de leur emprise psychologique sur des
personnes et se livrer à des abus
sexuels
à partir de ce moment là il a décidé de
mettre en oeuvre une immense lessive en
quelque sorte à travers les églises du
monde entier il a créé des commissions
des procédures il a modifié le code de
droit canonique et c'est de façon à ce
que les choses changent et ça évidemment
ça ne lui a pas valu que des amis parce
que ç'a porté atteinte à un certain
statut du prêtre il faut bien le dire et
et vis-à-vis des homosexuels on pense
que enfin on attend ce à dire que le
pape françois et à plus de bienveillance
à l'égard des homosexuels que dans la vc
prennent effet faire vous le pensez
aussi alors globalement sur les
questions de ce qu'on appelait ya pas si
longtemps la morale sexuelle
le père françois s'exprime très peu il
s'exprime beaucoup plus sur les
questions d'éthique publique
d'injustice sociale économique politique
que sur les questions d'éthique privé ça
c'est disons c'est la toile de fond
parce qu'il sait il vit voilà les
positions de l'église sont connus
l'église est contre l'avortement je suis
contre l'avortement tous les pas pour
lutter contre l'avortement
nous considérons qu'il faut préserver la
vie depuis son tout début jusqu'à sa
toute fin donc ça ça ne bouge pas en
revanche sur la diversité des situations
personnelles sur la diversité des des
chemins vécue par chacun
là ils considèrent que l'église pour
reprendre santé en deux doit se
comporter comme un comme un hôpital de
campagne comme un lieu on accueille tout
le monde comme un lieu où on doit
pouvoir écouter toutes les difficultés
alors il ya eu un épisode récent un
propos de cette question de
l'homosexualité
c'est donc un document qui a été publiée
par la congrégation pour la doctrine de
la foi donc l ancien cet office qui est
le lieu où le dogme et vérifier proclamé
etc et donc il a été dit clairement que
les prêtres ne pouvait pas bénir des
unions homosexuelles
ok ça a été dit le document précisé que
ce texte avait été publié avec le
consentement du pape
bon et puis on a constaté que dans les
jours qui ont suivi il ya eu un vent de
révolte épiscopal à travers le monde et
que des évêques et pas parmi les
moindres c'est à dire l'archevêque de
chicago l'archevêque de brisbane
l'archevêque de vienne
l'archevêque de
anvers en belgique se sont prononcés en
disant écoutez au stade où on en est
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus dire ça on
ne peut plus dire ça nous avons dans nos
communautés paroissiales des couples
homosexuels
ils sont engagés dans la vie de la
paroisse ils sont pratiquants il
témoigne d'une foi qui est une véritable
foi au nom de quoi pouvons-nous leur
refuser une forme de reconnaissance
alors c'est là que tout se joue c'est
sur la question de la forme de
reconnaissance
évidemment l'ensemble de l'édifice
anthropologique de la vie de l'église de
l'église catholique est fondée sur la
différence sexuelle et donc à partir de
ce moment là on peut comprendre que le
mariage hétérosexuel et préféré au
mariage homosexuel
il n'empêche que entre ces deux extrêmes
ces deux positions extrêmes il y à
d'autres il y a des tas de possibilités
et donc le pape françois a laissé faire
cette fronde épiscopale et puis ensuite
il a pris contact avec un couple de
journalistes de ses amis qui sont des
vaticanistes elisabeth piqué qui est une
journaliste argentine qui est une intime
du cardinal bergoglio à bono crs
autrefois et son mari gérard o'connell
qui est un excellent vaticanistes
canadien est en gros il leur a laissé
dire dans la presse italienne que
finalement ce texte de la congrégation
pour la doctrine de la foi
certes il avait publié mais qu' il y
avait aussi tout une latitude possible
d'attitude de comportement d'accueil et
que donc l'église catholique se devait
de faire preuve d'une grande ouverture
et derrière ça il ya une autre
difficulté qui est celle du pape c'est
que les l'église catholique d'allemagne
s'est lancé dans un grand synode depuis
déjà plusieurs années plusieurs mois
enfin un certain temps et que il ya des
puissances importante
il ya des
faction disons des tendances importantes
au sein de cette église qui veulent
officialisé la possibilité d'une union
homosexuelle d'une bénédiction d'une
union homosexuelle et là une partie du
vatican a voulu afficher un feu rouge en
avec la signature du pape le pape a
donné son accord
et par ailleurs il est passé il a mis
les pieds dans une autre porte ancrée
klaus forte de façon à laisser circuler
le courant d'air voilà c'est un bon
exemple de ce qui se passe au vatican de
la position du pape françois de sa façon
de gouverner et des difficultés qui sont
les siennes et l'écologie alors le
christianisme a toujours choisi les
hommes contre la nature et même contre
les animaux est ce qu'il est ce que je
veux tout changer dans ce domaine lui
aussi non alors le pour mémoire le
christianisme a choisi l'homme avec la
nature l'homme avec les animaux c'est à
dire que le mot clé pour comprendre la
vision chrétienne de l'écologie c'est
l'homme doit être un attendant le l'on
doit apprivoiser la nature il doit
évidemment pas l'épuiser alors il se
trouve que benoit 16 mois j'avais vu un
certain nombre de textes publiés par
benoît 16 qui déjà insisté sur la
catastrophe climatique est en
perspective et sur les mesures à prendre
mais le pas françois a décidé de mettre
le paquet là dessus et donc son
encyclique là où date aussi est une
encyclique est une encyclique très très
fortes en matière d'écologie pour la
protection de l'environnement pour la
protection des hommes et des femmes qui
dépendent justement des difficultés
vécues par l'environnement et puis il a
toujours fait le lien depuis son
élection
entre la justice économique la justice
sociale et la justice écologique pour
lui sa forme à tous mais il y a très
très loin le pape n'est pas un
antispécistes le pape ne va pas nous ne
va pas vous dire que l'homme est un être
vivant parmi d'autres êtres vivants au
même titre que les arbres ou que les
animaux en ce cela
en cela le pape reste chrétien et ne
renoue pas avec une forme de paganisme
ou de druide isme anciens même si
certains de ses opposants le lui
reproche et évidemment locaux vides
alors qu'est ce que ça a changé chez ce
pape qui veut tout changer à dire
écoutez ce peuple s'est retrouvé en cage
et comme il dit je suis ici en cage au
vatican
on se souvient de ces images absolument
incroyable des célébrations pascales il
ya exactement un an dans une basilique
saint pierre qui était vide avec le pas
françois qui s'est adressé seul à une à
la place saint-pierre vide pour une
déclaration urbi et orbi adressé au
monde entier je crois que le pape a une
conscience aiguë de ce que l'aco vide
révèle des faiblesses du monde révèle de
notre désillusion de notre consommation
à outrance des illusions de la violence
et que donc le pape souhaite de toutes
ses forces à partie de ceux de cet
événement majeur qui réunit tous les
hommes dans la détresse
il souhaite que à partir de là et tous
ces textes le disent depuis quelques
semaines et quelques mois à partir de là
une nouvelle réflexion puisse s'engager
pour plus de justice écologique sociale
et politique
je sais pas s'il va être entendue mais
en tout cas c'est exactement au coeur de
ces deux ses préoccupations et c'est ce
que beaucoup de ses opposants qui sont
climato-sceptiques lui reprochent
notamment du côté américain par exemple
ou ailleurs dans le monde
tout ça forme un tout les oppositions
aux par françois sont très très comment
dire le profil est clair c'est l'église
d'avant c'est les climato sceptiques
c'est les prêtres qui ont du pouvoir
c'est la collusion avec le pouvoir
temporel
c'est ça qu'on retrouve d'une certaine
façon le choix de de l'irak son premier
voyage lui qui se plaignait d'être
engagé son premier voyage
alors il était prévu peut-être de longue
date mais mais l'irak pourquoi l'irak
alors l'irak parce que c'est une
fracture
ce pape qui n'aime pas voyager a fait 32
voyage ces voyages nous emmener sur les
fractures du monde il faut se souvenir
que le voyage à bangui jusqu'au dernier
moment on s'est demandé si l'avion
pouvait atterrir dans la capitale de la
république centrafricaine et le pape a
déclaré si le commandant de bord ne veut
pas atterrir je sauterai un parachute et
donc l'irak c'est pareil le pape a bien
vu que lee l'irak depuis 40 ans souffre
de tous les malheurs possible du monde
dictature embargo invasion étrangère
abandon par la communauté internationale
invasion par des shs fuite des chrétiens
c'est le lieu de fractures par
excellence jusqu'au dernier moment ce
voyage est resté incertain jusqu'au
dernier moment l'entourage du pape a
tenté de le dissuader de ne pas s'y
rendre et jusqu'au jusqu'au dernier
moment il a dit j'y vais il faut y aller
et souvenez-vous il a fait ce voyage à
l'époque où aucun grand leader mondial
de voyages
on ne voit aucun président prendre
l'avion aujourd'hui pour aller à l'autre
bout du monde
donc il a eu ce courage là alors il est
vacciné l'ensemble de sa suite été
vaccinées tous les journalistes les 70
journalistes qui l'ont accompagnée ont
été vaccinées alors il faut balancer le
pour et le contre de ce voyage
évidemment le pur c'est que ce voyage a
fait circuler parmi les chrétiens locaux
et même parmi tous les ai tous les
irakiens un courant d'espérance
absolument formidable parce que enfin
quelqu'un à s'intéresser à eux pour leur
bien en dehors de tout objectif
politique stratégique ou industrielles
mais en même temps on a vu les images
notamment dans le nord on a vu les
images de ces foule agglutinée on a vu
lima les images de ces gens qui
portaient pas le masque et on sait
aujourd'hui que l'aco vite se répand en
irak
on peut pas dire que c'est lié à la
visite du pape mais néanmoins bon voilà
et puis les opposants du pape ne
manqueront pas de dire que certes le
pape se rend sur les lieux de fractures
et de souffrance du monde
mais voyez la situation à bangui en
république centrafricaine en république
centrafricaine n'a pas beaucoup changé
depuis que le pape s'y est rendu et dont
on peut se demander si la la situation a
beaucoup changé en irak
mais le pape se situe sur le plan du
symbole et du geste d'espérance et de ce
point de vue là ce ce voyage a été un
grand succès qu'il faut souligner quand
même pourquoi les les papes se sont ils
mis à voyager je crois que c'est pas le
6 le premier qui quitte l'italie depuis
le black précédent c'était celui qui
était venu en france pour sacrer
d'apollon et qui fêtait retrouvé
quasiment prisonniers sur notre
territoire mais les papes ne voyageais
plus on parlait de jean xxiii
il est contemporain de john kennedy john
kennedy prend l'avion pas jean xxiii
jean xxiii reste à rome il n'en bouge
pas paul s'il se met à voyager il fait
quelques voyages et et puis c'est
surtout jean paul ii qui va énormément
écumé la planète
mais pourquoi un moment se sont ils mis
à voyager je pense qu'ils ont été
emportés par le mouvement de la
mondialisation et que le responsable
d'une église universelle ne peut pas
échapper à ceux à ce mouvement là et
d'aller visiter les communautés sur
place et puis il faut se rappeler que
jusqu'en 1929 les papes se sont
considérés comme comme prisonnier au
sein de la cité du vatican et que les
papes ont eu du mal à digérer la perte
de leurs états pontificaux et que donc
il ya cette mentalité peut-être un peu
un peu carcérale qui a subsisté pendant
un certain temps au sein au sein du
vatican dont il faut se féliciter du
fait que l'église catholique universelle
a su élargir ses mouvements à l'échelle
du monde entier et depuis
même les papes qui avaient des
difficultés à voyager enfin moi j'ai
accompagné le pape benoît 16 dans bon
nombre de ces voyages c'était à la fois
très émouvant et très dur de voir à quel
point cet homme était fatigué
j'ai épuisé et de le voir devant un
million de personnes le matin deux
millions de personnes le soir c'était
quelque chose de très très fort et l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles les
journalistes vaticanistes ne croyait pas
en l'élection du pape vers golliot c'est
qu'on disait ce pape des tests 20 ce
cardinal déteste voyager
ben voilà il a déjà fait plus de trente
cinq voyages il était très triste de ne
pas poursuivre ses voyages pendant la
crise du coc vide merci frédéric monier
d'avoir passé une heure avec nous a
parlé du club françoise rappel le titre
de votre livre le pape qui voulait
changer l'église c'est paru aux presses
du châtelet
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]